次のセクション セクション二番目に入ります
これセクション一ですよ
今瞑想のね カタンチャ
アナンダ ページはえっと何ページでしたっけ
一枚は終わって 二枚 二枚目の一番下の段落左側
おそらく二百三百ページですね
三百ページの最後の段落
カタンチャ アナンダ セーコー
パティパドー イダ アナンダ
ビックーノー チャックナー
ルーパン ビスワー ウッパジティ
マナパン ウッパジティ
アマナパン ウッパジティ
マナパ マナパン ソーテーナ
ウッパンニーナ マナテーナ
ウッパンニーナ マナパ
マナパニ ママ マナパ マナパン
マナ パーリ語も読めなくなってきた
マナパ マナテーナ アッティーヤティ
ハラーヤティ ジュグッチャティ
次の単語はセーコーパティパダという単語なんです
パティパダは知ってるでしょう
意味は パティパダっていうのは道というね
実践ということですね
実践やって道である セーコーパティパダって何なのかと次にお釈迦様は質問を出すんです
セーコーっていうのは皆様知ってるか言いますと
日本語訳する場合は有学とセス
有学と書くんですね 有学
有学って漢字は何でしたっけ？ 有と学
有という漢字と学問の学
そういうもう一つ単語があって
無学と日本語訳するんです
では どちらが上ですかね
有学ですか？無学ですかね
文字通りに言えば 有学というのは学問があるであって
無学といえば学問がなしでしょうに
普通日本語で読んじゃうと
もう無学の方がバカで有学の方が頭がいいということになるでしょうね
仏教用語の使い方は違うんです
有学っていうのはまだまだ学ぶものはある
無学っていうのは学はなしで学ぶものはなしってことです
だから無学の方がもう卒業しています
有学の方がまだ勉強中なんです
そこでセーコーパティパダっていうのは
修行中の人の道は方法は何なのかっていう言葉なんです
修行中 セーコーっていうのは
ただヴィパッサナー始めただけでセーコーという有学と言わないんです
まあ言っても構いませんだけど
まあ本当にこれってヴィパッサナーかっていう感じでね
もう 三十分座って瞑想すると
大体ね 二八分ぐらい寝ていてね
残り二分前なんとか考えずやって瞑想するとはちょっと言いにくいんだけど
あの 結構進んでくるとかなり世界が変わるんです
実況中継の世界は で そこでこのウペッカーっていうことね
あの 前説明したレベルになったならば有学なんです
感情が瞬時に冷静に持ってくることができる
も問題なし もうそれがあり得る一番短い時間
音を聞いたら瞬時に冷静になる
音を聞いたら気持ちよくなるのは
まあそれ瞬間出来事 それは自然法則だから
そこは管理できん 次の瞬間でも同じ
そこはもう最短距離でやる
できたところで有学なんです
もし三十秒かけるならばね
まだまだ有学というタイトルはつけられません
まあ他の感情でも怒りでも欲でも生まれたら
それが落ち着くまでは
まあちょこっと十分ぐらいかかったそうと言ったらね
私は有学そうと言わない方がいいんです
一応あの前のセクションで説明したレベルに達したならば有学です
それから有学 有学になった人の道は何なのかが次のセクションなんです
だからさらに一段落 一段上なんです
というわけで ここからは皆様にはもうちんぷんかんぷんかもしれません
関係ないわけじゃなくて
ここからは理解しようとしてもその理解じゃありません
覚えておいてください
まだ第一セットをね やってないんだから
そこも合格していないんだからね
合格した人に限ってわからせたいもの
で わかろうとすると もうほとんど誤解すると思います
では どういうことかと読んでみましょう
イダ
ーナンダ・ビックーノ・チャックナー・ルーパン・ヴィッスワー・ウッパ・ジュティ・マナータン・ウッパ・ジュティ・アマナータン・ウッパ・ジュティ・マナータ・
アマナータン・ソーテーナ・ウッパンニーナ・マナータ・ウッパンニーナ・アマナータ・ウッパンニーナ・マナータ・アマナータ・マナータ・アマナータ
それ口語で間違いないか
マナータ・マナータ・マナータ・アッティーヤティ・ハラーヤティ・ジグッチャティ
その三つの単語 アッティーヤティ・ハラーヤティ・ジグッチャティ
この三つの単語もお馴染みなんです
辞書を引いてみたってお馴染みなんです
それでまたインドリアに戻る
目でものを見る 見ちゃったところで喜びが生まれたり
嫌な気分が生まれたり
あるいは両方生まれたりする
それは自然法則 そこまで
そこで お覚になった人は瞬間に帰る
それに 瞬間に帰ることができたらお覚なんです
次に別な修行をするんです
もう冷静になることはもうなってます
瞬間に 冷静な心であの感情にすりて
例えば花を見て気分が良くなったでしょ？あの感情が
あの心 心地よさ 心地よさに対してアッティーヤティ
これ嫌な気分だと ものすごく嫌な気分なの
なんかもう 何と言いますかね
なんかすごい不浄なものはお仏が体に落ちたような感じで
すごく嫌な気分になる
心地よさだけじゃないんでしょうね
何かものを見て気持ち悪くなったら
それについてだっても同じことなんです
だから我々はなんかね
ものすごい汚いものを見たら気持ち悪いって嫌な気分になるね
それじゃないんですよ
それが感情なんです それで覚えてください
何かものすごい腐ってる
もう動物の死体見ると気持ち悪くなる
花を見る 気持ちよくなる
どちらでも感情なんです
その感情についてすごく嫌な気分になること
だからその嫌な気分というのは全く別なものなんです
皆様にはもうまだまだ理解できる気持ちじゃない
あの仏教用語で嫌悪と書くんですが
それも漢字あてているだけで意味が通じたわけじゃないんです
それは実践する人にしかわからないんです
だって汚いもの見たらどうせ嫌な気分になってるでしょうに
それじゃないんだからね
だからまあ 例えで言えば
誰か自分にの体に汚物をかけたような感じに気分になる
で 汚物かけられたと思ってください
その時はそのものから離れたいという気分が生まれるでしょう
早くも体綺麗にしたいんだと
そのその気持ちなんです
だから嫌な気持ちと言ったってちょこっと意味は違うんです
体に汚物かけられちゃうと
もうどうやってもいられないでしょうに
もうそのうちに もうあの人をぶん殴る暇ないでしょ
何するのかとかね 警察署に行くぞとかね
そのまま警察署に行ける？訴えてやるぞとかね
勉強されてできない もうそんな余裕ない
もうすぐ先にもう体綺麗にするという気持ちになるんです
その気持ちに似ているんです
だから相当修行進んでないとできないんです
だから これ花を見てみたら生まれたあの心地よさに対しても
その気分になる 汚いものを見たところで生まれる
あの心地悪さに対しても
離れたいというね もうとにかく離れたいと
という気分になります
だからアッキエテ ハラエテ
ジグッテ ハラエテっていうのは離れたい
もうもう取っ払いたい
もうという意味で ジグッてていうのは汚いと感じる単語ですから
この 3つの単語はおなじみなんです
アッキエテ ハラエテ ジグッてて
それは現れた気持ちよささ
気持ち悪ささとか なんとかという感情について
汚物の扱いをすることなんです
それできるためには まず冷静になってもらわないと成り立たないんです
そこで耳で音を聞いたら
気持ちよくなったり悪くなったりするでしょうに
音楽の人はそれについても同じ
もう汚物から離れたいような
似たような気分になる
鼻で香り嗅いだところでも
あの気持ちから離れたい気分になる
汚物の感じになる 舌で味わった時でも依存しない
冷静になって こんな気持ちはもう離れないという気分になる
体にものを触れた時も同じ
頭で考えた瞬間でも同じ気分になるんです
これはヴィパッサナー瞑想のウペッカーという境地に達した人は
すぐにニッビタという
これは智慧と悟りというんです
ウペッカーという悟りに達したら
すぐにニッビタという悟りがあるんです
悟りなんかたくさんなるんですよ
悟る前に で 他も同じですね
6個も同じ気分になること
それが成功パティパダ
この修行と一応卒業したではなくて
ヴィパッサナー修行を完成した人が次にこれに挑戦するんだよと
ゼンニーディ出身イーに対して
それで 2番目のセクション終わったと
次にあるのは 3番目のセクション
カタンチャ それから 301 ページの 2番目の段落ですね
カタンチャアナンダ
アリヨ ホーティ バハビタ インドリヨ イダナンダ ビックノ チャックナ ルーパントィッサ ウパジャティ マナパム ウパジャティ アマナパム
ウパジャテ
ィ マナパ マナパム ソー サチ アアカンカティ パティックーレ アパティックール サニュイ ヴィハレイヤンテ
ィ アパティックール サニュイ タット ヴィハレティ サチ マナライ
次に バハビタ・インドリヨという言葉です
バハビタっていうのはバハヴァナの過去分詞なんです
完了形なんです ということは成長したっていうことなんです
インドリヤ・バハヴァナっていうのは現在進行形の名詞で
六根の修行 バハビタ・インドリヤっていうのは六根の修行を完成したっていうことで
完了した 次の質問は ではこの六根に対する修行
成長完了した人ってどんなものかと
いわゆる有学から無学になった人
例えば体に誰か体中汚すかけられちゃうと
私たちはもう瞬時そこから逃げたいでしょ
きれいになりたいでしょうに
その人はとにかくもう体きれいにするんです
そうするともうきれいになったっていうこと
だから あの あの六根から生まれた感覚についてすっごく嫌な気分になった人
すごくこの汚す気持ちになった人はもうすぐきれいになりますと
完全に それがバハビタ・インドリヤ
無学になったって いわゆる悟ったっていうことなんです
だから三番目のセクションは悟った人の世界なんです
だからなおさらわからなくなる
その人はもう同じく目で花を見る
いろんなものを見る そうするとマナートも生まれる
いわゆる心地よさも生まれる
アマナートも生まれる
気持ち悪いことも生まれる
たとえ悟っても しかし
その人はサチ アアカンカティ
望むならというか その気持ちならということ
パティックーレ アパティックール サニュイ ヴィハレイヤン
もしその人がこう考えたら
これは本当は不浄なものであると
汚いんだと 普通は でも私は汚いものなのに
そうではありませんという気持ちでいるんだよ
例えば犬のフンを見る
フンすげちゃう 気持ち悪いでしょ
それは僕 普通にすると
気持ち悪くないようにするそう
すればできますよと 思ったら
[背景音楽]それからとても美しいものある
するとみんな欲が出るでしょうに
例えばすごいごちそうを見る
見たらもうやっぱり欲が出てくる
それで完成した人なら
この場合はごちそうではなくて
気持ち悪いものとして見る
思ったらできる それで他の人はなんて美味しいごちそうでしょうかとかね
テレビなんか見るとみんな泣くでしょう
あのタレントさんたちが
あれはもう人を騙すヤラセでないならばね
よっぽど人生は不幸でしょうね
食べ物を見て泣くって日本人でね
あれって日本文人に対してツッコミ八つ当たりやと思いますけど
そんなにも見栄っ張らないかと
大体まあ 下手な人々っていうのは
色んなご馳走あって すごい冷静にはいるんですけどね
それはまあそれで普通の人々なら食べ物を見ると
やっぱりそこよろしいそうとかね
という気分になる それで修行を完了した人にとっては
これはえらい汚いもので感じてやるそうと
ただできるんですよ 本にとってはすっごく汚いものでいるんです
気持ち悪い 例えばゴミもの
ゴミの山 誰でも汚く見るじゃん
これはすごく綺麗なところだと
何のこともないという穏やかな気分でいるそうと思ったら居られる
例えば札束がいっぱいあると
みんな目がくらんじゃうかもしれませんだけど
完成完了した人だったら
簡単なゴミでしょうと思っちゃおうと思ったら
ゴミとして見える なんで役に立たないゴミですかね
これはと メモぐらいは書けないしとかね
迷惑やというふうに思うこともできる
いわゆるこの瞬間 この気持ちにいるから
これすごく難しいよ 演技なら誰でもできますけどね
でも気持ちは違うんだからね
タレントさんたちにね
すごいご馳走あっても見て見ないふり演じてくださいったらやりますよ
みんな くっだらないものを見せて
ちょっと驚いてくださいったらすごく驚いてくれるんですよ
もう金のためにね まあそういう猿芝居はいくらでもやりますからね
だから見て本物は本物
本当の気持ちはどうでしょうかと
で 本当の気持ち変えることは修行完了した人にできます
だから何でもできるっていうこと
普通の人は心地よさ 感じる所について
まあもうそうで反対の気持ちでいられるし
普通に人は心地悪いと感じるものとして
すごい気分よくいることもできるし
どちらでもできる自由自在ということ
それで自由ということになるからです
食べ物を見て これは美味しいことにしようか
まずいことにしようかという感じなんです
では 美味しいことにするぞと
やっぱりまずいことにするぞと
どちらでもできます だからダイエットなんかしたければすごい簡単です
やっぱり じゃあまずいことにします
ちょっとまずくても食えない
食えない もう食べられません
こんなまずいということもできます
そこでまたもう一つできます
彼にはダンラクのラストの三行下から
サチヤカンカティパティックーランチャアッパティックーランチャパドゥバヤンアビニワジェットア
ダンラクの下の三行のところ読んでます
ウペッカコヴィヘレイアンサトーサンパジャノ
もしその人が思うならばね
不浄か不浄でないかね
こんなことは全部やめちゃって
私はウペッカーで冷静にいると
気持ち悪いと思わないで
気持ちいいとも思わないで
では捨てるそうとウペッカーでそうと思ったら
サティを持ってね 気づきを持ってウペッカーで見る
入れますと その時はサティというファンクションが機能する
気づくというファンクション
その時平静にいるんだと
それから六根にも同じ文章で
目で物を見て 耳で音を聞いて
鼻で香りを嗅いで 舌で味を感じて
体にものを触れた時も同じ管理できる
とても簡単に 自由自在に
で 頭で物を考えたっても興奮することなく
いくらでもとんでもないつまらないことにしてやっても
では面白くしてやるぞと思ったらできるんです
すごいみんな面白がってることですけど
面白くないようにすると思ったらできるんです
あるいはどちらでもなく冷静でいようと思ったらそれもできる
それがインドリヤバーヴァーナが完成した人の境地
そこで皆様に一つ理解してもよろしいと思います
これが阿羅漢たちの心の中身なんです
たとえ沙羅ってのも世の中で誰にもバレませんよ
阿羅漢ですということは
人にバレることじゃありません
人に批判できませんだからね
その微妙なこの気持ちの自由自在っていうことは
だから例えば阿羅漢の方が見つけて
あの ごちそうを振る舞われたんだと
あげる人々は欲があるんだから
これすごく美味しそうとかも思ってる
阿羅漢たちも何のことなく
まあそれを召し上がったと
あ すごく美味しそうに召し上がったと思ったってのは
向こう側はどんな気持ちでいるかとか
それはわかりません 向こう側が
まあこの人の食べ物を褒めてあげなくちゃいけないと思ったら
誰よりも立派に これはこういうこういうことですごく美味しいでした
もうシェフプロプロみたいな感じで褒めることもできます
皆様だったら ああ美味しい
ああそれだけでしょ 私はそのばっかり話を聞くと
この人味覚わからないみたいと思っちゃうんですね
鈍感みたいだと だから微妙な色の差があるんだからね
食べ物に だから褒めようと思ったらそれもできるし
逆もできるし 自由自在になるんですね
だからこの阿羅漢に達した人々は
大体そういう この常に簡単に管理しているんです
それまだ自然なんです
管理 管理能力ついてる
それでインドリヤバーヴァーナは完了と
インドリバーナ まず始める方法
それから進んだらどうするのかと
進んで完了したらどうなるのかというセットでこの説明しています
それでインドリバーナ六根
六根を成長するということはこれで完了なので
これ以上は語るものはないんです
だからバラモンさんとはえらく違います
教えが これで経典は終わります
イティコワーナンダ 最後のページ
三百二 イティコワーナンダデーシターマヤ・アリアッサギネーアヌッタラーインドリバーヴァナ
このようにアーナンダ
私はもう説明し 説法しました
聖者の世界のインドリバーヴァナについて説法しました
デーシと成功パティパド
有学者の道も説明しました
デーシとアリオ・バハビティンドゥよ
無学者 悟った人の教えも説明しました
全部終わったよと 教えて
ヤンコワーナンダ・サッラー・カラニヤン
指導者として 先生としてやるべきことがあるならば
サーヴァカーナ自分の弟子たちに
それからヒテーシ・ナ・アヌカンパケーナ
先生として弟子たちのことを心配して
弟子たちの成長を期待する先生が心配して何かやるとするならば
カタン・ゴータマ私は全部やりましたよ
私はあなた方のことを心配する先生として
指導者としてやることはすべてこれでやりましたよと
先生の役目は果たしましたよということなんです
エータンがエーターニ・アーナンダ・ルッカ・ムーラーニ
アーナンダ ここら辺で木はいっぱいありますよと
ルッカ・ムーラっていうのは木の下なんですね
いくらでもあるでしょうと
エーターニ・スンニャーガーラに
あちら空き家とかあるでしょ
誰もいないところだって木はあるでしょう
あっちこっちいくらでも
ジャハヤと瞑想しなさいよ
マーパ・マーガって 怠るなよと
マー・パッチャー・ヴィッパティサーラ・ナ・アフーアった
後で後悔するなよ 今修行しないと
アヤン・ゴー・アン・マーガン・アヌサーシム
これが私に私にできる指導ですと
というところで経典は終わります
で これで中部経典も終了しますからね
一応決まり文句で終了したかったんですね
中部経典そのもの で この経典で仏道を全部語っています
悟るところなんです ずいぶん短いことで
だからたくさん経典読まなくても
ただこれしか知らないぞと言っても悟れます
それがブッダが昇華者たる所以なんです
語るものは完璧ですということで
欠落するものはなし 補うべきものはなし
疑問になるものはない
ということで すごい完璧な経典です
これは完璧に修行方法
悟る方法を説明している経典です
最後の行はイデモウチバガ
お釈迦様はこれで解きました
アッタマナーヤ・スマーナンダ・バゴッタ・バーヒサン
アーナンダ尊者がお釈迦様の説法に喜びを感じたということで
それはピリオドですね
経典後で付け加えちゃうと困りますから
後で何も付け加えられないように鍵かけるんです
で終わりです どれだけこの経典のポイントをしっかりと
日本語訳もありますよ
日本語訳も 日本語訳はどこまで訳してるかどうか分かりませんだけど
覚えておいてください
このインドリバーナ六根の修行というね
やり方とかね 原因Ｂ摂取に感情が出てくる瞬間で
どれぐらい早く冷静になれるのかということね
では終了しましょうか
皆さんはご質問など  はい
あの説明もよくわかったつもりなんですけども
実際日常の我々の商売なんかでは
逆に欲に訴えて興奮させてものをですね
売るというようなことをやっていると
皆さんがあまり興奮されると物が売れなくなるんです
まあまあ この経典はね
だからビクタヒに語ってます
あの若者は置いておいて
アーナンダさんじゃなかった
まあ事実はね まあ物を売るっていうことはね
欲の世界ですからね まあそうなりますけど
しかし 物を売るために生きてるわけないでしょ
我々は商売するために生まれたんだよとかね
映画作るために生まれたんだよ
それで映画作ったら天国に行くんだぞとかね
というのはおかしいではなくて
それは地獄になってるんだ
そんなことを言ったらという
はっきり言うんです 芸術家は芸術は命だと
たとえ親の死に床にも行けませんよと
それよりは舞台にいるのが仕事やっていうのはね
地獄に行きますよ それぐらいの
まあそれはもう日本ではね
舞台とかなんとかいうといたら
もう半年前からもう準備して
みんなチケット買ってね
まあ待ってるんだから
これみんなに迷惑というならば
それはまたちょこっと話別ですけど
それじゃなくて やっぱり芸能人というのはそういうものやって
そこを威張るんですからね
だらしないのはいいところなんです
それはもう地獄の道なんですよ
だから商売するために人の欲をあおいで感情をあおる
金儲かるために生まれたんじゃなくて
我々一人一人 人間としてどう生きるべきかというところで
一人の人間だからね その一人の人間が年老いて死ぬでしょう
だからこの世の中で短い時間しかいないでしょ
だからそれで人間としての人生を完成しなくちゃいけない
商売は成功したっても
人間としてどうでしょうかという疑問になるんですよ
日本一いい弁護士になったそうと言っても
あなた人間としてどうでしょうかとという疑問が出てくるでしょうに
だからそこは基本的なんですね
商売やろうか やってなかろうかと関係ないんで
人間であることはより大事なんです
そこで人間というのは興奮しちゃうと失敗するんです
犯罪を起こすんです 犬猫になるんです
それで商売できるのかと
できなくなるでしょ どんな仕事もできないでしょ
[笑い]だからあらゆる冷静でいないと弁護士もできませんし
医者の仕事もできませんし
教師の教師の仕事をできませんし
商売人の商売はできませんし
もう会社の相談したっても
相談はうまくいくはずがないでしょうね
政治家が国際会議やってもうまくいくはずがないでしょうに
だからすべてうまくいくためにも冷静でいることがもう先決で
これにはけちつけることはどうしてもできないんです
例えば欲をあおいで商売するのを仕事やってきた
では欲に溺れてみてください
ここで商売はストップになった
だから  これは美味しいものですよと冷静に言えば
いや 結局お客様が死んでるんです
美味しいでしょうにったら逃げますよ
買ってください これでもうかります
まあ結構いい値段だと思いますけどね
言えばまあ 本人買う人を一切感じないんですよ
何のこと？うちではもう大体厳しく品質管理してますから
まあ何でも心配できますから
それだけでうまくいきます
冷静でいれば これはああいう場所でもこういう風に選んできましたよとかね
私は一人でいて 一個一個リンゴを調べたんだよと言っちゃうと
誰も信じません この人はなんとか怪しい
とにかくもうとにかく強引に売りたいんだよと
逃げろっていう気分になるんです
冷静にいると まあ一応うちのリンゴはね
まあちゃんと産地で調べて
いろいろ化学物質入らないようにとか
まあそれしっかりやってますけどとかね
ちゃんと管理監視していますと
まあ何しろこれは悪くなっちゃうとね
こちら商売上がっちゃいますから
そこら辺はね 真剣にやってますと
言うと すごい冷静な言い方でしょうし
過度な宣伝でもないでしょうし
真摯らしいでしょうに
なんのことなく商売繁盛する
罪も犯してないことになる
というわけで あの感情の波に流されないで冷静にいるっていうことは
ものとてつもない大事なことなんだ
普通の人間よりはもうものすごく能力が上がるんです
はい そういうこと ではこの方よろしいでしょうか
悟るというのは生きながらにして死ぬということなんでしょうか
どうやって生きながらにして
その一つの臨死体験のような状態になるということ
そんな切っ掛けなものじゃないんです
悟った人は皆様よりはもう何百倍も何百万倍も元気で生きてますけど
何にもめげないしね 何にもすぐちゃくなってます
だからもう理解できんですよ
お釈迦様 これが究極な教えと言ってるんだから
生きながら死んでる連中いくらでもいるでしょうよ
あの山梨のあのなんとか呪回あるでしょ
ちょっと歩いたらもうもうもうこれから自殺する
自殺する勇気もなく 勇気もなくてテント張って生活する人もいるしね
そういう情けないだらしないことじゃないんです
なんとかして理解したいという気持ちはあることは分かりますけど
まあね それはやっぱり頭では理解できる世界じゃないんです
では もう一度慈悲の瞑想を少しいたします
生きと知るものが幸せでありますように
生きと知るものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きと知るものの願い事が叶えられますように
生きと知るものの悟りの光が現れますように
生きと知るものが幸せでありますように
では どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます